he's like what do you do I was like oh
I'm a dancer he goes it's probably AIDS
what the [__]
[Music]
so uh everybody familiar with Bruce
Willis's situation well I heard about
them no Armageddon yeah yeah he has to
[__] Save the Planet yeah he has to
save the planet and he's and he's a
drill technician yeah um no but his
condition has progressed to now having
frontal temporal dementia his family
says all right for those of them who are
stupid like me who is Bruce Willis whoa
that's cool I haven't heard that I don't
know
90s action Superstar some of the biggest
you've probably seen his movies like
yeah I don't watch a lot of movies I
watched like avatar the Last Air no you
don't know his face either no have you
seen the sixth sense no have you seen
Die Hard any of them you know it started
with a Vengeance it is kind of like
understandable like from a younger gen
you probably wouldn't run into him very
much yeah he's uh he's of the older
breed because his main hits are from
like the 90s and his movie is probably
not sure like it's probably not in your
demo movies they really watch like TV
like I watch YouTube videos more than I
watch movies
he's like the guy okay but he's like a
little further back yeah he's in Pulp
Fiction oh you haven't seen Pulp Fiction
I see Pulp Fiction I do like that you
said you watch Avatar Airbender though I
have uh an oppa and a Momo stuffed
animal
um I've been um Aang for the I got a
costume custom fitted
huh you go bald or not no I have this
it's a mask but I put it on backwards so
people think they're talking to me when
it's actually my the back of my head do
you know the guy that plays Zuko no
Dante Bosco yeah he comes here sometimes
yeah he's one of our friends tell him
the voice of Zuko oh wow
[Laughter]
see boys
I did really well like a year ago it was
like some someone's saying sit down and
you don't and then it's like a picture I
at first at soccer and then I did Zuko
and like sit down and then it's like I'm
sat
but um but then people were like they're
16 what's wrong with you and I'm like
I've been watching
Watchung right they would have grown
with me yeah right in my mind I thought
we were going to talk about Bruce Wilson
we're talking about Dante Boston I guess
we first got Google's sexy ass five six
boys is he five six Dante boss how tall
is he what's the sexiest what's the
sexiest voice ever though he's he's
taller than that is he a sad boy in real
life or does he just sound like a sad
boy no he's the coolest guy he's the
coolest freaking dude he's the coolest
guy in the room yeah the greatest energy
is the best the best so Bruce Willis has
dementia yeah yeah that's sad man we
keep forgetting that we're talking about
that yeah yeah so in a heartfelt
statement Willis's family including
ex-wife Demi Moore and daughter rumor he
was married to Demi Moore yeah I feel
like we talk about that every time we
talk
well he's not that skinny no he's pretty
skinny especially in Like That 70s Show
he was pretty skinny oh yeah he could
look like a machine gun Kelly but like
without that attitude yeah
he's Goofy and I love the goofy man but
he's also very intelligent and like in
tune with himself emotionally if you
hear him talk about like him and his
brother and like that whole stuff like
he's very intelligent and like emotional
with her yeah but um he would never go
for me so how come he couldn't find his
car
tell me one thing here these are the
questions we need to be asking on this
show yeah the drugs
so Bruce Willis so Bruce Willis has
dementia damn that's sad man and
um and he was married to Demi Moore
and you get sad for them but they could
be having the time of their life in
their own brain yeah but it's really sad
for his family at least oh yeah I mean
here's the thing I feel like I can laugh
about it my grandma didn't know who I
was starting at I was 12 and she lasted
like another 10 years and I'm like
that's a long time to not remember your
own family ten after yeah she'd always
ask are you Grant's girlfriend my
brother excuse me [__] she would
remember my brother and not me
every time and then they'd we'd have to
show her a picture of me like I am your
granddaughter and she's like oh Leanne
it was my original name I changed it oh
you changed it oh yeah just middle
middle switched it
um but yeah so it's like and but then by
the time she was old she was thinking
like the people trying to change her
diaper we're trying to burn stuff and
that's really dude that's rough yeah
that's hard that's not the golden years
of dementia the golden years the [__]
are really fun because my Grandma had
dementia too and golden years one of the
funniest things the prime the one the
funniest things is so my grandma uh she
has to take all these medications like
high cholesterol and all this stuff
right and then
um she would always want you know when
your dementia gonna have to go on this
like repetitive movement so they're like
oh I didn't think I'm gonna do my
medicine and then my grandpa and my my
aunt Robert no you took it already so
now
um but she would want to take double so
to make sure she doesn't take double
they would make her sign like after she
takes it like on her little tablet thing
yeah so that she can go back and go like
okay fine I did take it I'm not gonna
take anymore but then it got really bad
where now she thinks people are like
forging her signature yeah so seeing her
and like my aunt and my grandpa like
fighting back and forth like who forged
the signature and the stories that she
comes out was like one of the funniest
things you know what I heard that's the
golden years that's the golden years
dude I whoa okay what a turn oh that was
like The Sixth Sense dude yeah that was
the best the golden years for my grandma
is when she started accusing my mom of
stealing her money I'm sitting a theme
here dude they get paranoid dude yeah I
think so after a while right how could
you not though yeah this particular one
frontal temporal dementia known as FTD
is actually a little bit more uh I guess
um
aggressive uh these areas of the brain
the temporal lobes of the brain are
generally associated with personality
behavior and language oh so he's just
acting out probably and doing strange
things huh and it'll probably just get
worse over time as well at this
particular moment he's just officially
like retired from his career of acting
and stuff so he's like officially hung
up the curtain he's in his 60s how old
is he if it's maybe 70s I think no
really
he's 67. okay
very young for that
yeah I'm not a [__] doctor but I've
been told that like your hormone levels
like when you're younger like you need
to like go to hormone specialists
because it can affect dementia when
you're older oh so like that's why
health is so important playing a very
long game oh a thousand like that I go
yeah but a lot of doctors try to
Gaslight you like oh you're fine like
you have to go to a good doctor because
most doctors suck that's true they don't
know [__] I had mold poisoning for years
and every doctor is like no you're fine
no you're good mold poisoning yeah like
black mold in my lungs and then finally
after I think in your room it was in
your room it was from college the drugs
it was like in the walls and stuff at my
townhouse
um but then I went to doctors for years
who were like no you're fine no you're
fine [__] you up dude and then finally
I had a doctor take me seriously after
what like three or four years after I
graduated I was sick in University so
like I've had it for over five years
what was your symptoms uh of like the
mold poison that [__] [__] with your my
face so this was my
was my insecure for all these years my
body wasn't absorbing food or water very
well so it's like I'd eat food diarrhea
like okay but yeah I would drink water
pee right away it's like I could drink
two gallons of water in an hour and
still feel so dehydrated it was like
crazy
um and my body just always looked really
like there were a lot of things going on
that were just like undiagnosed but it's
like everyone kept thinking I had
diabetes and I'm like no I don't have
diabetes but like my symptoms didn't
sound like mold poisoning they sounded
like diabetes all these doctors so they
would check for diabetes and nothing
else yeah because they're Googling yeah
yeah yes
they're at chat gbt that's a theme like
a lot of times like when you go into
um like you see a doctor a lot of times
with your your symptoms are a little
funny they're like they're they could be
multiple different things they don't
take you seriously a bunch of times oh
dude yeah of course like I'm dealing
with that with my wife we've been saying
all these [__] doctors and they're
like yeah you'll be fine it's no big
deal it's probably just a rolled ankle
or some [__] maybe because they deal
with so many hypochondriacs 100
application I don't I don't think a lot
of people are hyper contrast I just
think most medical professionals don't
think okay this can cause this like they
just want to mask a lot of issues like
okay here's some pills for your
heartburn but what causes the heartburn
what are you intolerant to what could be
causing it that's just Western medicine
yeah yeah that's true that's a
pharmaceutical industry going through
yeah and they only have 10 minutes to
see you yeah yeah and then and then for
them afterwards once they leave they
have to like put it in the notes
sometimes they don't put the notes in so
then the next one well they're trained
to the child with prescribing you
medicine that's their whole thing that's
like me going to [__] when I'm in
China and stuff and I'm like Yo dude I
got this cake here can I get somebody to
like kind of like adjust me and then so
I'll get taken to a acupuncturist and
then yeah he'll come out and then he
won't like talk about anything to do
with my issues he'll just start making
tea with like [__] 16 different pots
and stuff like that yeah and then he
just like touches my hands and stuff and
he's like you haven't been sleeping well
and then you'll start saying all this
[__] profound [__] and they'll never
actually touch the spot but it'll fix me
yeah yeah dude that's awesome
problem and I went in and then he didn't
know what it was and then when I said
he's like what do you do I was like oh
I'm a dancer he goes it's probably AIDS
what though you can't [__] hit fire
that [__] and Lester
it was a doctor that I went to and he
just he was like I don't know what it
could be it could maybe dad sings it
sounds good
you look like a gay dude you're probably
HIV positive I was like bro he goes
we'll find out in 30 days I was like
dude what the [__] yeah so we did a full
blood test he goes come back in 30 days
we'll be able to tell you you should
have changed it real quick no no I'm a
firefighter but now
oh it must be fourth degree burns thanks
genius
I had a concussion in December head
banging accident and I went to the ER
because I was like it's been two weeks
and I'm still incredibly dizzy they saw
me they wouldn't do a CAT scan they
wouldn't do an MRI because they're like
no it's just a concussion you'll you're
you'll be fine and I'm like I just need
like that peace of mind because a lot of
acupuncture I was seeing an
acupuncturist or I still am but she's
like I need to know like what's going on
on your brain to give you the accurate
they wouldn't do it and they still try
to charge me like two thousand dollars
out of pocket from insurance I was like
what's the itemized receipt because you
guys saw me for five minutes and told me
to leave so they said I was anxious can
I pull it back a little bit yeah you
said you got a concussion head banging
yeah you're at a concert doing this
um my one friend bless her soul
um her Instagram was official Bronze
Goddess but she's had it deleted many
times
um she thought it was a great idea to
try to grind with me while I was head
banging very aggressively and then sure
had just banged into mine because you
know if I'm going like this why would I
be checking to see if someone's trying
to grind with me why would I be looking
so she hit right here which is my third
concussion in the same area oh that's
bad you get concussions in the same area
a lot huh and third one I get them on
the back too yeah yeah first one was
hiking
um and it an ankles a lot huh yeah any
other repetitive yeah remembering
injuries uh tendonitis I get that I
don't know if that's an injury but I
used to like run a lot and now I can't
because the tendons around my ankle will
start to hurt oh yeah shin splints oh
I gotta yeah so she got did she get a
concussion no because it was her like
right here and there's a lot more
padding right yeah so she was like I
don't know why you don't hate me for
giving you a concussion I'm like because
I know you didn't mean to it's just like
maybe drink a little bit and you had
brain fog for weeks it was a solid month
of um damn dude yeah like feeling really
out of it and feeling dizzy and it's
like I had to have my mom come brush my
hair like you're like a fighter she gets
extreme sports injuries without doing
extreme sports yeah headband grinding
don't do it I broke these four ribs I'm
taking a shower
I'm like damn how you get more injured
than I do doing the whop dance that's a
funny [__] story it just means I
can't dance